with halo infinite's campaign being
released and me just recently finishing
that campaign i wanted to put together a
story explained video for all of you as
while you were exploring the open world
or dying constantly from jackal snipers
you may have forgotten or missed a few
key points in halo infinite's story one
quick formality however if you enjoyed
this halo video and want to see more i
made an entire retrospective on the main
installment of the franchise prior to
infinite's release i also plan to
release a future video in the coming
days critically reviewing the story of
infinite as today's video is simply a
retelling not a review and finally
spoiler warning as always i'll be
spoiling the entirety of the game so
you've been warned with that out of the
way let's get started first and foremost
i want to recap the story of halo 4 and
5 so the proper context is given if you
don't need a refresher then you can skip
to the time on screen and get right into
halo infinite but to recap halo 4 is the
start of the reclaimer saga and is where
the chief in the unsc infinity get
introduced to the prometheans and the
died act but more importantly we also
discover cortana is suffering from
rampancy most ais have a lifespan of
seven years and cortana has been around
for eighth so she is way past her
digital expiration date we can see her
slowly getting worse and worse as she
emp's the systems of infinity's control
room and just outright stops listening
to the chief at certain points in the
game later during the final moments of
the died act bossfight cortana splits
herself into fragments and uses those
fragments to defeat the dyed act but due
to the immense power this requires she
ends up sacrificing her life to save the
chief and we end halo 4 assuming she's
gone until halo 5 begins and the master
chief accompanied by a blue team are
clearing out a nearby ship argent moon
where he gets a message from cortana to
meet her at meridian which we discover
is a forerunner planet since chief is
disobeying orders this is what forces
fire team osiris to hunt them and bring
them back to the infinity blue team
discovers cortana is in fact alive
thanks to her somehow going through a
slipspace portal and discovering the
domain a forerunner network that in a
roundabout way cured her rampancy with
this newfound discovery she explains
that the ai can now hold the mantle of
responsibility this is an ideology that
is pretty much the main cause of the
covenant human war and also what's
happening in the reclaimer saga as a
whole but essentially this is about a
race of beings dedicated to for a lack
of a better term being the guardians of
the galaxy originally humanity was to be
the successors but cortana is going
against the forerunner's original wishes
and instead wants the ai and her
newfound faction the created to be the
rulers but she is using it in a very
imperialistic way as anyone who joins
her is spared but those who don't will
perish blue team ends up meeting with
cortana and is captured until fire team
osiris saves them during this encounter
cortana calls out to all the species and
ai in the galaxy to join her while we
don't hear any species we do hear
hundreds of ai answer her call which
causes them to revolt against those who
created them which is why the infinity
is in a state of panic towards the end
of the game as numerous colonies and
planets are experiencing widespread
outages after blue team is rescued by
fire team osiris cortana then escapes on
her 4-runner guardian in hopes of
finding the unsc infinity in an attempt
to destroy it but the infinity manages
to evade her tracking by slip spacing
multiple times halo 5 then ends with the
master chief in spartan lock meeting
with dr halsey palmer and the arbiter on
sang helios halo infinite picks up where
the legendary ending of halo 5 ends as
we get a shot of zeta halo the new ring
will be exploring an infinite shortly
after we see a war breakout between the
unsc and the new faction the banished
i'll explain both the ring and the
banished in a moment but for now let's
carry on during this conflict the chief
can be seen attempting to stop the
banished forces until atriox the
faction's leader completely wipes the
floor with him he then tosses the chief
off the ship and into space we then get
introduced to echo 216 better known as
the pilot or later in the game fernando
he is alone on a unsc pelican and is
just trying his best to survive we can
see how long he's been on this pelican
as his facial hair has grown quite
considerably during the scene he hears
the ship's ai say there is a friendly
life force nearby which is how he
discovers the chief he then takes the
chief inside and boots him back online
we then get a quick shot of zeta halo
being broken and then are able to start
playing so now let's explain what that
ring and the banished are the ring known
as installation 07 or from here on out
zeta halo is the ring we traverse
through in halo infinite and what we
know about the ring zeta halo is three
times larger than any normal halo ring
we've seen in the series the ring back
during the time of the forerunners was
inhabited by ancient humans but during
the forerunner flawed war faber the
master builder of the forerunners used
it to perform flood experiments thus
killing lots of its inhabitants he also
left the ring under the control of a.i
mendican bias the most advanced
forerunner ai to ever exist during an
experiment run by the master builder
medicine bias would test-fire the halo
ring but this caused a huge problem as
this awoke the primordial it is said to
be the last living precursor in the
entire world primordial would then
transfer its consciousness into a grave
mind like the one we see in halo 2. the
forerunners were very concerned about
this discovery so they locked it up
again leaving mendican bias in charge
however the primordial is quite
deceptive as it was able to convince
mendican bias to side with him which
caused the primordial to break out of
containment releasing all the flood on
the halo ring lots of other small
details occurred between now and then as
that was almost a hundred thousand years
ago however what's more important is
that to anyone's knowledge mendican bias
and the primordial may still very well
be alive and on this ring as for the
banish they were introduced in halo wars
2. they're a mercenary faction that
split off from the original covenant
empire they're sort of like joel
madame's covenant which was a splinter
group form from some of the covenant's
original soldiers except they differ in
a few ideologies the banished are led by
warmaster atriox and are primarily
composed of brutes however they do have
other species within their ranks they're
a group that is all about power
constantly throughout the game esheram
will try to challenge us as they crave
the hunt killing and hunting stronger
foes to prove that they're powerful is
what they do its four most important
members are atriox decimus asheram and
jega the blademaster decimus was killed
in halo wars 2 and since he was second
in command within the banish the
runner-up would take his place which was
esherum we already know about atriox and
esherum from just the few missions in
game but the only outlier of the group
is jega probably the coolest character
in the entire game as he has earned the
title of spartan killer all of them
minus decimates are the main characters
of the banished and halo infinite and
will constantly appear throughout the
game to continue back to where we left
off originally i was going to explain
the rest of the story chronologically
from the game's point of view but then
that got too convoluted so i'll try to
establish an actual timeline of events
there's been quite a lot of time between
halo 5 and halo infinite if i'm not
mistaken it's been about three years
since then so cortana has had a lot of
time to plan her attacks throughout the
game the chief will hear whispers and
see echoes of cortana these are assumed
to be fragments of her memories that the
chief can somehow see we first see
cortana talking to an ai called leonidas
he was in charge of laconia station and
was allied with cortana she orders him
to sacrifice himself and leonidas
self-destructs killing all the unsc
soldiers and spartans on board the next
one is her talking with lord hood from
halo 3 about earth's surrender even the
homeworld of the unsc isn't safe from
her jurisdiction to provoke them she
even summoned her guardian who was
waiting to fire in case things didn't go
her way according to the master chief he
witnessed the guardian completely
eliminate sydney australia so it seems
that lord hood was not budging on her
offer the final echo we see is her
talking with atriox where she goes one
step further and threatens the entire
banished homeworld atriox of course
refuses to align himself with her and
the entire planet of dossier is
completely destroyed in front of his
eyes cortana has gone completely mad
with power and is not willing to listen
to anyone as we enter the final mission
we get even more echoes but this being
about her and atriox the first echo we
see we hear cortana talking about
waiting for a specific person to show up
and asking what that plan is questioning
what halsey will think if they try to
destroy her she thought the person that
walked into the room was chief however
it was actually atriox once again to
provide more context throughout the game
we get a few bits here and there about
what's going on with the weapon
essentially in between the events of
halo 5 and halo infinite the master
chief was tasked with the deletion of
cortana he had witnessed the destruction
on earth and all the other planets he
destroyed and realized that it was time
to come to terms with reality cortana is
not the same cortana he once knew as
that one died in halo 4 and this new one
is one that seeks vengeance so despite
their relationship together he wanted to
see his mission through dr halsey then
created another ai who we know as the
weapon her task was to mimic the
original cortana so that she could be
lured onto zeta halo and be trapped
there after being trapped cortana would
then be deleted and so would the weapon
as she served her purpose which was to
capture cortana however while the weapon
succeeded in trapping cortana the chiefs
did not get to her first as atriox beat
him to her going back to the echo we see
that atriox and cortana meet together
atriox says that cortana's empire is
over and that he's here to discuss her
terms of surrender atriax goes on to
explain that he has discovered immense
power within this ring and what the
silent auditorium truly is he wants
cortana to relinquish control of the
ring as that's all atriox wants with the
power of the halo ring underneath
banished control they could wipe out
galaxies without even trying so cortana
devised a plan and ends up blowing up
the halo ring with the ring broken it
can no longer fire preventing atriox and
the bandish from claiming it as their
own from what we can gather shortly
after this it seems that cortana
sacrificed herself to blow up the ring
not the halo 4 split into fragments then
become an immortal sacrifice i mean this
time she seems truly dead this explains
how cortana the weapon and atriox got
here and why the ring is destroyed with
that out of the way we can fast forward
to present day towards the end of the
first mission we discover that atriox is
dead we have no clue how or when we just
know that he died this is completely
untrue but once again more on that later
the master chief with the help of the
pilot lands on zeta halo as he has one
mission in mind stopping the banished
from controlling the ring and
subsequently firing that ring the
banished are trying to activate the
spires on the ring as the spire's main
jobs are to rebuild the parts of the
ring that have been destroyed the only
way for the chief to prevent them from
firing this ring is with the help of the
weapon our previous information explains
why he knows of the weapon's existence
and where it's located as he was tasked
with helping her delete cortana the
master chief meets with the weapon and
asks where cortana is she says that
cortana has already been deleted at the
moment the two don't know why but once
again previous info i've already talked
about explains why as she sacrificed
herself to blow up zeta halo so keep in
mind that two storylines are going on we
have the war against the banished and
cortana the chief is doing both at the
same time so things can get a little bit
intertwined most of the missions for now
are just about defeating the banished
and taking back the ring but eventually
we'll discover a banished dig site upon
entering this dig site we meet a monitor
named despondent pyre she's freaking out
currently as something called the
harbinger is awake and judging by her
tone this doesn't sound like a good
thing when we make our way through the
conservatory we hear despondent empire
being interrogated by this harbinger and
she talks about reviving the endless we
find her separated into multiple pieces
and we also get to see an echo of
cortana and despondent pyre pyre
explains that cortana may have the
weapons of the halo ring but its secrets
it holds can never be unearthed cortana
believes that pyre is talking about the
flood and explains to her that there are
more things dangerous on this ring than
the flood this is extremely terrifying
in so many different ways not only does
this confirm to us that the flood were
or possibly still are on this ring but
something far worse exists here seeing
as within this whole franchise the flood
has always been the strongest and most
terrifying force to go up against the
fact that there's something even worse
is a bit bone chilling pyre is freaking
out and trying to explain to cortana
that the punish must not be freed but
cortana refuses to listen this possibly
explains how the harbinger was able to
be awoken we eventually come face to
face with said harbinger and it's quite
clear that she is of a very different
species something we haven't seen before
the harbinger says that the forerunner's
lies are at an end and the endless will
be found justo talks about something
called the reformation after this the
chief then learns of the spires and
heads to one to take it down it's here
where we meet agitant resolution he's a
sub-monitor that was created to replace
the spawn empire should she be
decommissioned or destroyed just like
the guilty spark he doesn't take too
kindly to having his spire be destroyed
so he attacks us on sight the chief
defeats him and the spire is shut down
except only one of them is shut down
there are still 10 more spires to hunt
down but one of them has the control
room within it this is kind of like how
each halo ring can be fired separately
but can also be fired all at once from
the ark but instead of rings it's these
spires before we destroy it we get a
cutscene between the harbinger and
escheram atrox apparently found the
harbinger sometime during his travels
and decided to work together the
harbinger just wants to bring back the
endless she's fine with the banish
taking the ring so as long as each party
gets their goals met they won't meddle
in each other's affairs however this
alliance is very shaky as the two
definitely don't trust one another back
to the chief he had the weapon make it
through the 4runner structure to shut
down the spire however one of these
instances is very important throughout
this mission the weapon claims to have
been scanned by something that is being
watched by someone as a precaution
master chief seems to be doing something
with his suits software minutes later
when they get inside the control room
the weapon attempts to finish the
process but the harbinger stops the
weapon chief uses this exact same
software program that he did earlier if
you read the text that appears during
this he was trying to delete the weapon
in case she was caught or taken this
goes back to what the weapon said
earlier in that mission about wanting
the chief to trust her glee he doesn't
trust her at all as he almost deleted
her at the first sign of danger
something he would never do with cortana
this causes some discrepancy between the
two as the weapon trusts the chief and
is willing to do what he needs her to do
but despite all she's done to help he
still won't trust her because of this
encounter though the harbinger was able
to start the reformation process this
reformation is taking place at the
silent auditorium the area we were in
when we were talking about those echoes
with cortana and atriox before we can
leave we get another boss fight with the
sub monitor who is trying to kill us so
the harbinger can start the reformation
process it does come out eventually that
he was wrong as he didn't understand
what the reformation was but at this
moment he is still trying to kill us
afterwards the pilot comes to pick us up
until he's attacked and captured by jega
we've already seen jaeger's work in
action as he's killed all the sparrings
we take the abilities from but now he
wants to kill us and he's luring us into
a trap by using the pilot as bait the
master chief being the master chief of
course goes after the pilot and has to
go through the house of reckoning it's
an arena built by the banish so they can
hunt the unsc members they capture by
giving them weapons and a base to defend
themselves while the banished attack
them from all angles it's quite the sick
and twisted game after making it through
the basic and advanced version of the
arena we get into probably the toughest
part of the game as now we have to
defeat jega the room is dark with tight
spaces and very little room to breathe
jega also uses an energy sword and
active camo making this fight incredibly
terrifying after defeating jega we walk
10 feet out of the room and get into
another boss fight with escheram who is
also insanely tough but of course he's
the master chief so he'll prevail and
rescue the pilot the three then go to
the silent auditorium to stop the
harbinger this journey also ties into a
discovery that the weapon is cortana yes
she dresses and sounds like her but it's
not a coincidence she is a literal copy
of her in halo 4 cortana talks about
being replaced with another ai after
she's dead possibly even one that looks
like her well they weren't kidding as
the weapon is literally cortana just
without the knowledge of their
adventures she's basically pre-halo 1
cortana who only knew of the chief's
existence and nothing else the weapon is
clearly worried is now that she realizes
she's a copy of cortana she's worried
that she'll go rampant too but that's
also another mission the master chief
was tasked with preventing her from
being another cortana continuing into
the silent auditorium we make it to
where cortana sacrificed herself and
then meet the harbinger according to the
harbinger the place we're stepping foot
in is where the forerunners pass
judgment on the harbinger in her kind it
seems that she has some hatred towards
the forerunners because of what they did
to her and the endless which is why
she's trying to revive them we do
eventually stop her but before she dies
she mentions that while her time is up
and that she's been defeated the chief
in the weapons time is up too as it
seems like she was able to contact the
endless before her death right after
this we get another echo of cortana but
this one's a little different it doesn't
seem like a memory more like a planned
message for the chief and the weapon she
says her goodbyes but wants to apologize
for what she's done she admits that she
was wrong and that the entire reason
they're together was because they were a
team and her going off on her own was
stupid of her to do that cortana wants
the chief and the weapon to learn from
her mistakes and to not repeat them
again the two then escape the silent
auditorium together and reunite with the
pilot there's also this sweet moment
where the group exchanged names and we
discover that the pilot's name is
fernando fernando then asked the weapon
what to call her and judging from the
fact that she asked the chief for
permission it sounds like she's gonna be
going with cortana as her name the three
then discuss future plans as it becomes
clear to all three of them that the ring
houses something more dangerous plus the
banish still controls zeta halo so their
work isn't finished however while their
work is only beginning ours is done as
we reach the end of the campaign we do
get a post-credit cutscene which shows
atriox who is not actually dead
activating this device which opens a
room with a ton of forerunner slabs all
with a unique marking on it from what we
can gather from these endings i do have
some theories firstly the harbinger
talks about the endless this is either
the name of her species or the name of
the faction my first choice is a species
however there is an audio log from
despondent pyre that talks about an
uncatalogued species called the xalanine
my actual theory though is that the
harbinger is related to the precursors
and seeing as this endless group is
probably going to be our next threat
that means that we will finally be able
to see the precursors in game for the
first time with the post-credit cutscene
in mind it seems that atriox will
definitely play a large role in the next
story as he seems to have his own
motivations if any or all of this is
true this next game is going to be
insane but now we've officially come to
the end of the game and we've also come
to the end of the video thank you all
for watching today and hopefully i was
able to convey the story well enough to
you if you have any questions leave them
down below and i can maybe try to help
you regardless thank you for making it
this far in the video do let me know
your thoughts on the campaign and the
ending as a whole i'll be saving my
thoughts for that future review on the
campaign so look forward to that to hold
you over though don't forget to check
out my halo series retrospective video
as a lot of you seem to love it so thank
you all for the support on that with out
of the way like the video if you enjoyed
it subscribe if you're new and as always
thank you to my returning viewers for
coming back
take care everyone
goodbye
[Music]
you